hi this is pig peppers with a fine bears
frosting levels tutorial video this is
the second type of level that we run
into a candy crush saga saga and I'm
just going to play a couple of them and
show you how it works here we see the
intro we make a match over the ice you
can see the blue underneath it that's
where the bear is consumed and you know
ice has two layers when it's transparent
like that if you only need to make one
match over and they pop out so here we
can kind of see right when we start via
this is that you this by easiest level
of these is wrong but you can see we
have one big one 1 medium size 11
and the ice is see-through at this point
you can see the blue tinge so we can see
where they are
so I'm just going to play around a
little bit on this and this is nice i
have a little national freedom but all
up at once and when you met my match to
powder bombs together it creates this
like you know growing wave that wipes
out all the one layer ice that's on the
board so you can see that too it was
pretty cool
and there's our three bears
so in these levels the bears can move
around on some of them other ones will
be in fixed positions and like I said
already the you know the layers will be
it'll be double layer dice and most of
the time it's only usually within ice in
the very first couple so real quick
we'll look at one other one to see what
that looks like
this is a tough level that on that's in
the game now there's actually two
different versions wonders when it looks
like this and one has a on it has a
color bomb in a rat Canyon amount on the
boy but here you can see we have to find
20 bears and we can't see any of them
and we have these sort of like cupcake
bloggers covering the ice as well so we
have double arrow dice that's blocked
out by this so that makes things a lot
more difficult and I'm not really going
to try to beat the level i'm just going
to show you yet like see how when i made
the match over the double-layered ice it
became single layer now i can see that
there is a bear right underneath that
part if you're having trouble with level
13 we have a full guide on that that
explains how to be this loose version
you're going to link to the video for
the other one so i suggest you check
that out but you can see that there's
bears everywhere they're just hidden so
once you clear the blocker you see it
has layers just like you and the
meringues in the original game or
whatever once you clear you still have
double layered ice underneath it so you
don't you won't know right away where
the Bears are and if you you know if you
check out our guide then the trick to
this actual level is is this area down
here you need to you know make combos to
free this and clear out a bunch of this
at the same time otherwise you just
going to run out of moves but this is a
pretty level pretty simple level type
there's a lot of really tricky fun bears
level so it's not easy necessarily but
it's really straightforward the one
thing like i said is sometimes and some
of them the bears can move around
so the first time you play you might
think you know where all the Bears are
and attack that part of the board and
they might actually move before you get
to them so just kind of pay attention to
that some of some of you always be in
the same place so that's just a helpful
information and another tip would be
like I said that when you have blockers
and things covering the ice you're never
going to get past it just by making
matches like that you're going to have
to work towards setting up their calm
those click clear out big areas of ice
like I did in the first level and I'm s
your to pella balls together you're
going to want to fish aren't that great
because they only take off one layer but
they can be really good if you make them
in palm those like a combo on fish plus
collar bone fish plus cotton candy those
matches are really good for bears levels
because they'll clear out a lot of
blockers rice in one time so if you have
any questions leave comment if you have
um you know any questions on anything
the game you can leave comment about
that too please like the video if you
found it helpful and make sure you visit
candy crush soda saga tips com to learn
more about the game and get tips on the
hottest levels thanks